[Musique]
regardez en tout cas c'est léger la déco
de la poussette laissant les
interdictions de diffuser dans les
salles de sport des chansons dont le
rythme des passerelles et 120 battements
par minute objectifs limités et réguler
la transpiration la respiration des
usagers une sorte de en même temps qui
permet en fait de maintenir les salles
de sport ouverte mais d'éviter que les
sportifs sans voix un peu trop de
gouttelettes les uns sur les autres et
si vous vous approchez de vos collègues
à moins d'un mètre cinquante à faire le
test eh bien ça se met à vibrer à biper
50 visiblement oui je vais me rapprocher
de toi
le médecin que vous détestez aller
consulter ses parts à août là mais j'ai
peur je sais pas trop envie de kim
ausculte celui-ci là parce que j'ai
l'impression qui part dans tous les sens
après il a des diplômes mais sont ils
vraiment reconnue par l'état moi c'est
douste blazy mon sens très tôt dans deux
semaines le gérant de cet établissement
de plage de charente maritime devra
contrôler tous les passagers terre de
ses clients un casse tête
j'ai pas une entrée fixe avec une
réceptionniste qui vient les gens
arrivent vous voyez la jeune fille là
qui qui va commander au comptoir on lui
donne un bip qui viennent chercher se
mettent en terrasse
l'un d'entre eux a accepté de nous
répondre à de nîmes ans il propose sur
le réseau social snapshot dépasse
sanitaires car ça qui travaille pour
être à la sécurité sociale
d'accord
securitas à 50 me suffit simplement de
lui envoyer les coordonnées visant leur
numéro de sécurité sociale tout ce qu'il
ya sur l'ordi après me renvoie tout
voilà personne et c'est bon ça prend
entre 3 et 6 dans le même temps on vous
contrôle et ça il faut vous contrôliez
aussi la qualité pour être sûr que ce
bien que pour cela il doit recruter de
nouveaux agents assermentés un budget
supplémentaire alors que la saison
s'annonce déjà compliquée que tu n'es
pas on se comprend plus s'il ne le fait
pas il sera passible d'une amende de
45000 euros
et en cas de récidive jusqu'à un an de
prison et une fermeture administrative
une sanction qui passe mal allons
enfants de la patrie le jour de gloire
arrivé nouveauté cette année
chacun a dû présenter un pass sanitaire
en règle pour accéder au périmètre tôt
ce matin ses agents de la sécurité
civile était chargé de contrôler les qr
codes des faut attendre quatre jours où
la gadoue la gadoue
[Musique]
à gauche que les bayous baroeul a été
vaccinée la deuxième injection 1er
juillet et il compte 14 jours donc on ne
sait pas valable tous les ans je
regardais à la télé il faut le voir en
vrai c'est chez moi se dire qu'est ce
qui somme conséquente ses gammes alors
messieurs ce matin si je comprends bien
c'est rira bien qui veulent race sans se
dégonfler surtout comment est ce que
vous vous sentez ya c'est un beau bonne
d'émotion il ya beaucoup d'émotions il
ya du froid déjà il ya du 5 heures du
mat on est honoré aussi excité stressé
il ya plein de choses franchement il ya
plein de choses mais on est train
45 1 c'est uniquement sur france 2 alors
je vous promets anne-sophie que ce sera
comme toujours une très grande fête une
fête nationale merci stéphane j'ai vu
que vous aviez de nouveau mis vos
chaussures tricolore mais on peut pas y
aller comme ça c'est impossible
non ça c'était au top et il y en a un
des deux pour qui voilà ça c'est plus ou
moins bien passées non angot à
l'atterrissage tu as eu gérante
ce que je veux dire c'est un moment
romantique partagé par le compte twitter
de l'armée de terre
ce matin avant de défiler sur les champs
elysées un officier a demandé en mariage
sa compagne
la jeune femme a dit oui et son fiancé
lui a passé la bague au doigt attendez
deux secondes excusez moi c'est que je
fasse quelque chose alors dans monsieur
ça me dérange pas on a sympathisé
avenches s'ils n'ont pas permis bonheur
et la chance quand on tousse le pompon
ça y paraît vous retrouvez là bas j'ai
maintenant beaucoup moins
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un cavalier qui a chuté visiblement et
la suite sur le partir de 8h y aura des
marseillais
[Musique]
ça